bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo en compagnie
d'emmanuel kessler bonjour et bon jour
au menu de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire de la semaine le mea culpa
de la france à propos de la tunisie nous
avons sous-estimé les aspirations du
peuple tunisien à la liberté reconnaît
nicolas sarkozy le président qui
justifie cependant la discrétion
française par le devoir de réserve d'un
pays vis-à-vis de ses ex colonies le
chef de l'état qui est revenu cette
semaine sur un thème qui lui est cher la
lutte contre la récidive criminelle
après la disparition de laëtitia à
pornic il exige des initiatives rapides
mais il aurait renoncé dans la semaine à
en passer par une nouvelle loi qui
aurait été la sixième en septembre enfin
moraliser la vie publique c'est
l'objectif d'un rapport rendu cette
semaine par la commission sur les
conflits d'intérêts les ministres
cabinda et aux fonctionnaires de l'état
devrait par exemple faire des
déclarations d'intérêt à chaque année
question que va faire maintenant réviser
le sémaphore est notre invité cette
semaine pour commenter toute cette
actualité c'était elisabeth guigou
bonjour merci d'être sur le plateau de
la chaîne parlementaire public sénat lcp
lcp assemblée nationale vous êtes je le
rappelle député socialiste de seine
saint denis vice présidente de
l'assemblée nationale ancien ministe
vous avez occupé plusieurs portefeuilles
affaires européennes justice emploi vous
publié ces jours-ci pour une europe
juste au cherche midi un livre
d'entretiens avec véronique auger on
aura l'occasion de revenir sur certains
aspects vous faites partie de la
génération mitterrand celle qui est
arrivé au pouvoir il exactement 30 ans
et qui rêve désormais de reconquérir
l'elysée en fin en 2012 première
question peut-être certains au ps comme
françois hollande ou jean christophe
cambadélis dit cette semaine que le ps
est un peu parti dans une machine à
perdre vous partagez cet avis notamment
sur les primaires non voilà je comprends
pas qu'on passe son temps à s'auto
flageller comme ça alors que l euro
l'une de responsables politiques du ps
devrait plutôt de mettre en valeur le
travail important qui s'y fait même s'il
n'est pas encore très visibles et s'ils
n'ont pas encore abouti voilà le ps sous
la direction de martine aubry s'est
remise au travail nous avons tenu
plusieurs conventions dont une
convention internationale dans lesquels
jean christophe cambadélis a joué un
rôle important qui a produit je crois
des propositions intéressantes est forte
sur l'europe sur l'afrique par exemple
on va dire pourvu des événements
aujourd'hui à quel point nous avons
besoin évidemment nous européens de nous
tourner davantage vers notre sud
donc je trouve que nous avons mis en
place un comité du projet le calendrier
pour le projet défini nous allons avoir
une convention du projet présidée par la
première secrétaire femme est ensuite le
calendrier des primaires est fait voilà
alors après il ya des péripéties ya des
clapotis les applications
bavard comme dit cambadélis vous parliez
tout à ségolène royal qui dit pour
l'instant le ps n'a ni candidat ni
projet pour 2012 mais ça va lui dire
voilà on a un calendrier il faut le
respecter salut françois mitterrand m'a
appris et nous a appris quelque chose il
faut maîtriser son temps alors le temps
politique n'est pas le temps médiatique
ça c'est vrai moi je comprends que vous
ayez vos contraintes mais nous avons les
nôtres il n'y a aucune raison de
bousculer un calendrier qui a été adopté
d'ailleurs à l'unanimité par l'ensemble
des dirigeants du parti et alors c'est
vrai que moi je suis pas contente non
plus de certaines déclarations voilà je
trouve que l'on ferait mieux de dire les
dirigeants tous les dirigeants et
dirigeants du ps devrait se fixer une
seule règle dire aux françaises et aux
français ce que nous allons proposer
pour résoudre leurs problèmes il est
temps de faire est d'accord on passe on
va y revenir d'ailleurs sur certains
dossiers de la semaine on passe à la
journée de lundi tunisie malaise
français
conférence de presse de nicolas sarkozy
lundi sur les dossiers internationaux
pour la première fois le chef de l'état
s'explique sur l'attitude de la france
face à la révolution tunisienne et il
fait un début de mea culpa mylan poyet
devant le siège du gouvernement tunisien
ce matin la caravane de la liberté
arrive à son terme
quatre jours de marche depuis plusieurs
villes de province pour rejoindre la
capitale et exiger la démission du
gouvernement jugée trop proche de
l'ancien président ben ali
dans le même temps dans les écoles et
les lycées les enseignants ont entamé
une grève illimitée les tunisiens ne
semble pas en avoir fini avec leur
évolution révolution marquée en france
dans un premier temps par le silence du
gouvernement puis par certaines
maladresses ce matin en conférence de
presse début de mea culpa du président
de la république il y avait une
désespérance une souffrance un sentiment
d'étouffer dont il faut il nous faut le
reconnaître nous n'avions pas pris la
juste mesure sans doute nous avons
sous-estimé nous la france cette
aspiration de nos amis tunisiens à la
liberté mais dans le même temps nicolas
sarkozy se défend il invoque un certain
devoir de réserve face à ce qu'ils
appellent de vieux réflexes coloniaux
donc je revendique
une certaine réserve lorsqu'il s'agit de
commenter les évènements de pays qui ont
été la france et qu'ils ne le sont plus
plus tard nicolas sarkozy défend aussi
sa ministre des affaires étrangères
michèle alliot marie invoquant une
éventuelle maladresse dans la forme pas
dans le fond
et d'ajouter que la france a accueilli
durant plusieurs années des opposants au
régime tunisien
coïncidence avec l'actualité le parquet
de paris vient d'ouvrir une enquête
préliminaire sur les biens en france de
l'ex président tunisien
mme alliot marie est ce que vous
partagez elisabeth guigou cette idée du
devoir de réserve de la france vis-à-vis
de pays qu'elle a colonisé dans
l'histoire
certainement pas à la france de dire à
ces peuples ce qu'ils doivent faire mais
c'est certainement la responsabilité de
la france d'accompagner
par les encouragements à la fin dans une
parole politique et puis par le aussi
des gestes concrets
d'accompagner les mouvements de
démocratisation et je pense que notre le
gouvernement pas la france le
gouvernement s'est lourdement trompé il
a gravement failli parce que les
déclarations de madame alliot-marie
elles ont fait beaucoup de mal beaucoup
de mal moi j'ai eu énormément de
réactions de mes amis de l'autre côté de
la méditerranée pas seulement en tunisie
mais en algérie au maroc mais qu'est ce
qui se passe comment ce que la france
peut s'exprimer comme ça et madame
alliot marie elle a certainement pas
pris cette initiative tout seul donc on
comprend la gêne les explications ont
été données ne sont pas suffisantes
je crois que je crois que en réalité
le quai d'orsay
n'a pas apprécié correctement la
situation
il suffisait d'ailleurs on n'a pas
besoin de télégrammes diplomatiques aux
confidences sur sa qu'il suffisait de
regarder la télévision de bien les
journaux d'aller sur les sites internet
pour voir ce qui se passait donc le
gouvernement et le président a voulu
être aveugle curieux jusqu'au bout que
ils sont pas les seuls on a été un peu
en retard sans doute même le parti
socialiste aussi des recettes personne
ne pouvait prévoir le moment évidemment
mais enfin le mouvement de fronde qui se
passait quand on savait aussi que
depuis assez longtemps quand même
plusieurs mouvements se conjuguait s'ils
voulaient d'abord l'éducation qui
s'était propagée pas seulement en
tunisie mais dans d'autres pays aussi le
fait qu'il ya énormément de diplômés qui
trouvent pas de travail le fait que la
crise a pesé sur ces pays le fait qu' il
arrive un moment où quand on a surtout
quand on a un certain degré d'éducation
quand on se voit priver des libertés que
l'on voit accorder à d'autres sur tous
les écrans télévision sur internet la
liberté de s'exprimer la liberté de lire
les journaux de son choix la liberté de
penser s'arrête pour la tunisie est ce
que vous êtes né au maroc vous êtes vice
présidente du groupe france maroc on
voit qu'il ya un risque de contagion
maintenant dans tout le monde arabe est
ce que la france n'est pas trop
complaisante vis-à-vis du maroc mais
d'abord je pense que il ya des
mouvements qui sont comparables c'est à
dire une aspiration des classes moyennes
en particulier à plus de démocratie
et en même temps il ya des différences
entre les pays vous avez par exemple au
maroc un parlement avec des partis
politiques différents
qui sont reconnues qui sont des partis
démocratiques vous avez des élections
vous avez au maroc une certaine liberté
de la presse n'est pas parfaite sans
doute mais
voilà la situation étant un différend
est justement de démocratie pardon vous
qualifié le maroc de démocratie je pense
que vous savez je ne sais pas parce que
nous avons nos propres standards et je
pense que nous n'avons pas alors en
effet à les imposer aux autres je pense
qu'il ya encore des marges de
progression
et d'ailleurs les démocrates au maroc le
10 mai la situation n'est pas exactement
comparable qui était celle de la tunisie
en revanche la tunisie était plus avancé
sur l'alphabétisation par exemple sur la
scolarisation notamment dans les milieux
ruraux et si c'est pas la même chose
vous êtes en train de nous dire non
parce que c'est pas tout à fait non
c'est pas exactement comparable non non
bien sûr d'abord d'un côté vous avez une
monarchie qui est ancienne
de l'autre avec un jeune roi d'un autre
côté vous avez un dictateur qui est là
depuis plus de 20 ans
qu'ils commencent à être âgé quand même
voilà mais c'est vrai que
voilà il faut être il faut soutenir je
crois tout les mouvements de des
démocrates faut être aux côtés de ces
peuples sans leur imposer quoi que ce
soit car ils doivent on ne peut jamais
décrété la démocratie de l'extérieur
c'est à eux mêmes de trouver leur chemin
alors cette conférence de presse de
nicolas sarkozy ce lundi avait pour
premier thème l'économie mondiale quelle
ambition pour la france qui préside le
g20 et le g8 jusqu'en 2012 nicolas
sarkozy les a énumérés et parmi ces
travaux d'hercule pour une meilleure
gouvernance mondiale il a reparlé d'une
taxe sur les transactions financières on
écoute la france y favorable à une taxe
sur les transactions financières
la france considère que cette taxe est
morale compte
tenu de la crise financière que nous
venons de traverser
que cette taxe est utile pour dissuader
la spéculation
je pourrais m'en expliquer si vous aviez
des questions et que cette taxe est
efficace pour trouver de nouvelles
ressources pour le développement
alors une taxe sur les transactions
financières pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique pour aider au
développement ça pour est une
proposition du programme socialiste
saleh c'est une proposition dont vous
êtes d'accord avec le président c'est
une proposition du parti socialiste
européen depuis longtemps depuis
plusieurs mois c'est écrit noir sur
blanc la question est de savoir à quel
taux on va l'avoir nous nous disions une
taxe sur les activités financières de
0,05 pour cent et ce que nous disons
surtout c'est qu'il faut sortir des
proclamations d'intention on est au 6e
g20 depuis que la crise a éclaté à l'été
2008 alors on ne cesse pas d'avoir des
programmations sur le fait qu'on va
lutter contre les paradis fiscaux
rétablir de la régulation financière là
maintenant très bien créer une taxe
financière il faut le faire il faut être
une ipo à l'époque les américains soient
d'accord il faut créer d'abord les
conditions pour que en europe les
propositions de la france celle ci je la
soutiens totalement il y en a d'autres
puisse être soutenue or et ça c'est un
travail politique et diplomatique de
longue haleine et c'est vrai que on ne
se donne pas les meilleures chances
d'avoir le soutien de tous les européens
des allemands en premier lieu mais de
tous les autres quand on tire en
permanence la couverture à soi
pour avoir travaillé beaucoup des années
des années avec françois mitterrand sur
les questions européennes je sais que
une entente et une position européenne
lorsqu'elle vient lorsqu'elle est
proposée par la france ensuite ça se
construit avec les autres et je regrette
que nous ne soyez pas en position en là
on peut dire on peut déclarer à la
télévisions très bien est-ce que ça va
se faire je souhaite j'interviewe
nicolas sarkozy joue trop
franco-français dans un projet ça fait
bien sûr ça fait trois ans maintenant
que nous attendons des résultats sur les
paradis fiscaux sur une vraie règle vous
reconnaissez vous même c'est pas facile
dans votre livre veut rien savoir mais
parce que il faut au plan international
évidemment qu'elle est résistance enfin
les états unis d'obama sont allés plus
loin que l'europe sur un certain nombre
de sujets et je pense que nous avons
besoin
de resserrer la cohésion européenne et
certains accusent notamment l'année
dernière sur les roms qui sont
certainement pas aller dans ce sens on
passe à l'actualité et de mardi
l'euthanasie un débat inédit au sénat
permettra une personne majeure dans des
cas extrêmes d'être médicalement aidé à
mourir c'était le sens d'une proposition
de loi qui une première a été débattu
dans l'hémicycle du sénat mardi mais le
texte a finalement été vidé de sa
substance après la prise de position
hostiles de françois fillon les
explications de marie brémaud
les détracteurs de l'euthanasie semble
avoir eu raison du texte de loi qui fait
polémique au sénat alors que des
centaines de personnes pro life
manifesté ce matin devant la haute
assemblée au même moment la commission
des affaires sociales vider la
proposition de loi légalisant
l'euthanasie de sa substance les
articles de la loi ont été supprimés par
la même commission qui avait adopté le
texte de loi la semaine dernière il y a
une seule explication possible le
gouvernement a donné des consignes et a
demandé qu'il n'y ait pas de vagues ces
derniers jours le gouvernement françois
fillon en tête n'a pas ménagé ses
efforts pour battre le rappel contre le
texte la sénatrice à l'initiative de cet
amendement de suppression avance une
procédure parlementaire habituel et
réfute avoir coupé court à la discussion
n'a pas clos un débat puisque le
règlement du sénat permet au contraire
que le débat ait lieu en séance plénière
dans la nuit une majorité de sénateurs a
clos le débat 170 d'entre eux ont voté
contre la légalisation de l'euthanasie
le sénat at il bien fait selon vous
elisabeth guigou de rejeter ce texte
actuel moi je pense que on ne peut pas
légiférer
sur une question aussi difficile
douloureuse sur lesquels chacun alors
quelle que soit l'heure son appartenance
politique à sa sensibilité
je crois qu'on peut pas légiférer dans
la précipitation je pense que il y à une
loi leonetti qui a été adopté à une très
large majorité avant tout
fondée en 2005 groupes politiques
confondus et qui je crois a établi un
cadre qui permet à la fois de ne pas
avoir d' acharnement thérapeutique les
personnes sont en fin de vie et d'autre
part de soulager les souffrances par un
consensus des soignants avec les
familles
cette loi malheureusement et qui prévoit
le développement des soins palliatifs
pour les personnes en fin de vie cette
fois malheureusement on sait qu'elle est
très mal appliquée il ya simplement on
nous dit que à peine
1% des personnes en fin de vie peuvent
bénéficier en milieu hospitalier de
soins palliatifs c'est pas normal donc
moi ce que je souhaite parce que c'est
vrai qu'il y à quelques cas très très
spectaculaire d'ailleurs tel marginaux
mais mais vincent humbert médiatisé me
extrême qui ne rentrent pas dans le
cadre de la loi léonetti
je pense qu'il faut en débattre
calmement ce que je souhaite c'est que
surtout sur un sujet comme ça on se
précipite pas pour légiférer à nouveau
qu on évalue
les l'étendue des soins palliatifs je
crois que la priorité des priorités
c'est évidemment des généralisée pour
les personnes en fin de vie qu'on évalue
les effets de la loi léonetti sont
l'application et puis qu'ensuite en
effet on se pose la question de savoir
s'il faut d'autres d'autres mesures donc
cette initiative a au moins le mérite de
de reposer les problèmes de tweets on a
bien sûr sur ce débat de société il faut
constamment alimenté la réflexion c'est
vrai à léon ce mardi se repose aussi à
la question de la récidive pour les
crimes sexuels laetitia a disparu dans
la région de pornic et le suspect est un
homme déjà condamné 13 fois dont une
fois pour viols en visite dans la région
nicolas sarkozy exige de son
gouvernement et des parlementaires ump
des initiatives rapides on écoute
je souhaite que la justice travaille
très vite
très efficacement afin que toute la
vérité soit connue
jure serais je recevrai la famille
dès mon retour
mais je veux vous dire que la récidive
criminelle n'est pas une fatalité
et je ne me contenterai pas d'une
enquête sans suite
je le dis très sereinement
mais il y aura pas une enquête de plus
on dira aux français que tout a été
parfait sauf une petite jeune fille qui
ne demandaient qu'à vivre
et qui a disparu c'est pas possible
faut attendre de voir
mais si c'est l'indicible
fois des décisions
et pas des commissions de réflexion
donc des décisions pas des commissions
de réflexion qui a été ministre de la
justice qu'est ce que vous inspire ce
ceux plus jamais ça nicolas sarkozy
chacun d'entre nous est pauvre ni
l'émotion profonde
devant un tel crime
il faut pas retrouver cette jeune fille
donc c'est si vrai que c'est
insupportable
voilà alors maintenant il s'agit de
savoir ou de là encore
de grandes déclarations qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire d'efficace
nous savons très bien que pour ces
criminels dangereux
qui sortent de prison c'est le cas au
terme de leur peine ayant effectué la
remise de peine
et il faut un suivi étroit
or vous avez des conseillers d'insertion
et probation qui sont des travailleurs
sociaux du ministère de la justice ils
ont en moyenne 130 dossiers chacun de
criminels ou support présumés criminels
la sueur dans la région il disait 800
détenus avec ce détenu non suivis
pendant suivi 827 les jeux même lu dans
certains
n'ont suivi par des conseillers
d'insertion et probation
donc si vous voilà où est le problème le
problème il est con on devrait dès le
début de la peine dans la prison
suivre non seulement certainement
surtout les délinquants sexuels moi j'ai
fait voter une loi en 98 qui demandait
ça qu'il instaurait dès le début de la
peine est évidemment tout au long de la
peine et ensuite à la sortie un suivi
qui soit à la fois sociales judiciaires
mais cal de sorte que la personne comme
c'est le cas d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de
démocraties du nord de l'europe
d'ailleurs au canada soit enserré dans
une espèce de filet de surveillance hors
les murs
qui soit véritablement
qui encadrent et qu'ils soient aux
aguets les deux tout risque de récidive
voilà malheureusement on manque
dramatiquement de moyens alors plutôt
que de prévoir de mettre des assesseurs
aux juges dans les tribunaux
correctionnels
parce que là aussi il faut détruire non
les jurés populaires une initiative
sympathique par ailleurs je pense qu'on
ferait mieux de doter de se préoccuper
des vraies urgences en voici une
particulière et puis l'assemblée
nationale a également voté la réforme de
la garde à vue à une large majorité le
texte prévoit la présence de l'avocat
tout au long de cette étape de l'enquète
pour se conformer aux obligations
européennes
le ps s'est abstenu sur ce texte en 2000
vous aviez fait voter une première étape
avec en principe la possibilité pour
quelqu'un de s'entretenir avec un avocat
dès la première heure de garde à vue
alors pourquoi ne pas avoir voté pour ce
qui constitue aux yeux de tout le monde
un progrès du droit et qui va dans le
sens de ce que réclame l'europe qui est
votre un de vos soucis non mais le
gouvernement a fait voter cette loi
contraint et forcé par les décisions et
mais c'est bien taré par les décisions
européennes par le conseil
constitutionnel et par la cour de
cassation donc il a fini par se résigner
à faire voter une loi qui rétablit pour
les personnes gardées à vue il y en a
quand même 800 milles dans 200 milles
pour une infraction routière le droit de
se taire que j'avais instauré dans la
loi en 2000 la loi sur la présomption
d'innocence et les droits des victimes
le droit de se taire après que ce droit
de se taire et été supprimé par les lois
perben en 2003 2004 qui en effet rétabli
ce qu'ils s'étaient perdus la présence
de l'avocat et qui va d'ailleurs plus
loin et ce que je salue puisque l'avocat
est présent pendant les interrogatoires
tout le toit sont d'ailleurs alors
pourquoi est-ce que je n'ai pas voté ce
texte qui représente un progrès par
rapport à la situation actuelle
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
la présence de l'avocat n'est pas
absolument automatique que le procureur
peut décider que ça on comprend qu'il ya
des cas où il faut faire attention par
exemple des réseaux de
s'organiser pour fitter de l'avocat non
à partir du moment où l'avocat n'a pas
accès au dossier pendant la garde à vue
ceci ne peut pas se produire nous
parlons de la présence de l'avocat
pendant les interrogatoires c'est tout
d'ailleurs c'est l'intérêt à mon avis
des policiers parce que il ya toujours
un soupçon qui pèse compte tenu des
conditions matérielles déplorables dans
lesquelles et les policiers souffrent
eux aussi une âme ans effectue les
gardes à vue je pense que la présence de
l'avocat d'un avocat qui est là on
pourra 6 plus un côté de son client peut
être de nature à dissiper les soupçons
de maltraitance mais si je n'ai pas voté
ce texte aussi c'est surtout parce que
le contrôle de la garde à vue et
notamment sa prolongation devrait être
réalisée par le juge de la liberté et de
la détention qui est une disposition qui
avait été votée d'ailleurs par la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale et que le gouvernement a fait
retirer donc nous nous sommes abstenus
pourquoi pour dire ben nous ne votons
pas contre parce que c'est vrai qu'il
semblerait par rapport à la situation
actuelle mais nous estimons qu'il aurait
fallu aller plus loin avoir une loi qui
soit véritablement alors elle tout à
fait conforme aux standards européens
car le paradoxe c'est que l'europe nous
demandent avec insistance de réformer le
statut du parquet pour rendre les
procureurs enfin indépendants dans leur
carrière du pouvoir politique or ceci et
nous l'avons souligné dans débat n'est
toujours pas fait et évidemment tant que
ce sont des droits de l'homme risque de
protester et bien sûr et s'attend que ce
sera le thème ne seront pas en
conformité avec les standards européens
allez on passe au mercredi quand un
rapport s'attaque aux conflits
d'intérêts dans la vie publique
la commission sur les conflits d'intérêt
en ce mercredi son rapport au président
de la république avec des préconisations
très sérieuse pour imposer des règles de
transparence aux ministres à leur
entourage et à la haute fonction
publique et déclaration d'intérêts
obligatoire interdiction de cumul qui
s'inscrirait dans une loi un rapport
très exigeant qui suscite des réactions
contrastées johan raud là
au coeur du rapport présenté ce matin un
préalable définir dans la loi la notion
de conflit d'intérêts au terme de quatre
mois de travail et de 70 auditions ces
trois auteurs formulent une série de
propositions ambitieuses à commencer par
la suivante l'obligation pour tous les
membres du gouvernement ainsi que pour
tous les hauts responsables publics de
déclarer leur intérêt financier leurs
anciennes responsabilités et celle de
leurs proches une idée déjà détaillé par
martin hirsch dans son livre choc pour
en finir avec les conflits d'intérêts et
soutenu par de nombreux parlementaires
de l'opposition je crois qu'on a besoin
en france de ne pas être dans
l'implicite mais avoir des règles à
laquelle on peut se fier et qui soit
finalement au coeur de la recherche de
la confiance aujourd'hui une perte de
confiance on l'a vu beaucoup dans le
secteur de la santé la gauche craint en
effet une simple réponse cosmétiques à
l' affaire woerth bettencourt élément
déclencheur du rapport dans la majorité
d'autres s'interrogent sur la mise en
place d'une haute autorité de contrôle
pas question de se lancer dans une
chasse aux sorcières si vous mettez des
règles excessives vous allez finir par
mener l'action publique avec des gens
totalement
asexué incompétents ne connaissant rien
n'a rien et l'ayant de contact avec
personne la france sera pas beaucoup
plus avancé outre le rapport sauvé un
groupe de travail spécifique a été créé
en octobre dernier à l'assemblée pour
définir des règles de bonne conduite
pour l'ensemble des députés il devrait
rendre ses conclusions dès le mois
prochain
elisabeth guigou vous avez été entendu
par cette commission en tant que
représentante du ps sont évidemment pour
l'instant simplement des préconisations
va voir ce que l'elysée veut en faire ce
serait quand même une révolution des
mentalités moi je trouve que c'est un
excellent rapport mais j'y retrouve
d'ailleurs pratiquement toutes les
propositions que j'avais eu l'occasion
de faire au nom du parti socialiste
donc je crois que c'est un très très bon
rapport qui sort de neuss ne parle pas
des parlementaires qui ont leurs propres
gardes de travail est ce que on pourrait
s'inspirer de ce rapport alors ce que
j'espère c'est deux choses d'abord que
s'agissant des noms parlementaire
c'est-à-dire des ministres et des hauts
fonctionnaires des membres de cabinet il
est effectivement une loi qui traduisent
en actes législatifs
7 ses préconisations pour l'instant
c'est que des propositions ça ça dépend
du gouvernement du président de la
république de proposer ça en particulier
l'interdiction pour les ministres
d'exercer un mandat exécutif local
trouve que ça on doit absolument tenir
bon sur cette préconisation vous avez
évoqué vous même les déclarations
d'intérêts bon et puis il ya une
deuxième chose à faire puisque la
mission sauver n'était pas compétente
pour les parlementaires c'est que le
parlement assemblée nationale et sénat
définissent pour les parlementaires des
règles qui soient aussi exigeante que
celle du rapport ces violations
d'intérêt public aussi bien sûr est
rendu publié sur je crois que ce père
est avocat d'affaires alors c'est
compatible ou pas pour vous je crois que
je ne crois pas très franchement je
crois que monsieur copé cesse toute
activité avec une égide alors il s'est
pas tous les avocats parce que c'est
vrai on peut dire lac quand on défend la
veuve et l'orphelin quand on défend des
divorces août quand on défend des jeunes
pierre joxe aime beaucoup ça par exemple
devant la justice ça c'est autre chose
mais franchement l'activité d'avocat
d'affaires
je ne pense pas que ce soit ça peut pas
être résolue simplement par les
déclarations de laquelle puisque ça se
renouvelle en permanence donc ce qui est
vrai à un moment peut être toute assez
dépassé le lendemain donc je crois que
la sagesse serait de décider que on doit
s'abstenir
pendant la durée du mandat alors après
est-ce que ça doit s que vous avez les
médecins vous avez des avocats rageant
pour les médecins il est clair que est
rattaché un laboratoire pharmaceutique
quand on est député non en revanche on
va pas me semble-t-il interdire à un des
grands médecins d'exercer ou même des
médecins de campagne si vous voulez on
en a beaucoup donc je crois qu'il faut
apprécier les différentes situations y'a
pas à pas il n'ya pas des professions en
tant que tel mais pour le faire parce
qu'il faut pas que le parlement
apparaissent comme étant un ils ont bien
sûr préserver de toutes ces contraintes
alors dans la sphère du médiator la
mission d'information commencé ses
auditions à l'assemblée ce mercredi sous
la présidence du député gérard bapt
première entendue la pneumologue du chu
de brest irène frachon la première à
avoir alerté sur les dangers du médiator
témoignage édifiant ou la pneumologue
raconte en longueur les pressions dont
elle a fait l'objet et l'attitude de
l'afssaps agence du médicament extraits
qu'ils avaient beaucoup plus peur du
laboratoire très clairement à tous que
des conséquences qu'il n'imaginait pas
certainement en terme de gravité
de laisser faire je sais qu'il ya eu des
coups de téléphone au conseil de l'ordre
pour savoir s'il avait moyen de
m'interdire d'exercice qu'il y avait
donc l'évocation de recours à l'académie
de médecine aux académiciens qui avait
l'évocation de retour de recours à la
justice et puis un autre mail que j'ai
vu passer également redisait bien les
doutes qu'ils avaient sur la valeur
scientifique de notre étude je ne sais
pas s'il avait pu l'entendre sur la
longueur c'est un incroyable témoignage
où l'on mesure le degré d'infiltration
de l'ère des rouages de la
pharmacovigilance par le laboratoire
servier et à quel point il se sentait
démunis
quelles solutions qu'elle pour ces
conflits d'intérêt notamment on va ça
c'est une affaire grave ici blanc est
d'abord le rapport de l'igas est très
claire donc je crois qu'il faut en tirer
toutes les conséquences d'ailleurs qu'il
faut une refonte complète du système de
pharmacovigilance
parce que le gouvernement a commencé à
faire vous aviez bertrand s'y est
engagée la tue vous trouvez qu'il gère
bien ce dossier exhale côté je pense en
tout cas que il a annoncé des mesures
fortes et j'espère qu'elles vont être
prises voilà et c'est vrai que
il faut arriver
empêcher interdire que les personnes qui
ont un pouvoir de décision sur
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
déjà c'est ça qui importe surtout en
matière de santé publique premièrement
deuxièmement sur le plan économique sur
l'autorisation de remboursement par la
sécurité sociale c'est deux choses y
faire on veut dire l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché on apprécie la
l'innocuité ou
le caractère dangereux d'un médicament
pour le remboursement ou pas par la
sécurité sociale c'est son caractère
efficace ou pas donc je crois que la
traite absolument que s'agissant de ces
deux décisions fondamentales les
personnes qui sont amenés à les prendre
soit complètement indépendante des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques par
ailleurs
il est indispensable de pouvoir se
pencher sur le système des visiteurs
médicaux vous voyez des médecins qui
sont débordés par leurs pratiques
souvent qu'ils n'ont pas le temps de se
tenir au courant et c'est qu'ils sont
quand même constamment des marchés il ya
des sommes folles qui sont les supprimer
les visiteurs médicaux non je dis pas ça
mais très franchement regardez quand
même qu'elle ait
calé nous l'avions c'est nous quand nous
étions gouvernement quels sont les
montants des sommes est est ce que on
peut pas justement affecter une partie
de ces sommes si vous voulez à combler
plus tôt le déficit de la sécurité
sociale est quand même sur le
l'équilibré économique voilà moi je
pense que c'est
qu'il y ait des visiteurs qu'ils fassent
connaître l'existence de médicaments
mais là il a atteint des proportions
quelquefois terrible en revanche on
pourrait soutenir des revues
indépendantes comme prescrire qui elle
informe davantage de façon plus
indépendante je crois que c'est reconnu
les médecins sur les avantages ou les
inconvénients de tel ou tel médicament
si on ne finance ils y perdent leur
indépendance pardon mais on les finance
y perdre leur indépendance
mais c'est reconnaître c'est une façon
de faire connaître par exemple davantage
aux médecins allez on passe à la journée
de jeudi l'union sacrée sur le grand
paris
après trois années de rivalité de
dialogue de sourds même l'état et la
région ile de france se sont mis
d'accord sur les transports en commun du
futur autour de paris modernisation des
actuels rer et nouveau métro automatique
en rocade autour de la capitale y en
aura pour 32 milliards d'investissements
d'ici 2025 thomas souliers
après plus de deux ans de négociations
ils ont du mal à cacher leur sourire
l'état et la région ile-de-france ont
enfin conclu un accord sur le grand
paris 32 milliards d'euros vont être
investis dans les transports franciliens
d'ici à 2025
objectif moderniser le réseau existant
et réalisé en métro automatique autour
de la capitale
c'est un effort d'investissement
historique pour les transports il faut
du rêve il faut de l'utopie moi j'assume
cela on a aussi besoin des petits
cailloux blancs qui font que les
transport des franciliens vont
s'améliorer considérablement et un
véritable tournant économique social et
écologique pour l'île de gough après
avoir dénoncé la mainmise de l'état sur
la région jean paul huchon trouve
aujourd'hui le texte mesuré est
favorable aux franciliens mais cet
accord a du mal à passer au sein même de
sa majorité pour les verts jean paul
huchon a vendu son âme au diable
on était favorable à un rapprochement
d'être assez favorable à l'intérêt
général sur les transports en commun en
ile-de-france qui transcende les
clivages politiques mais pas favorable à
une opération de communication du
gouvernement auquel le président de la
région s'est prêtée et donc quand on
voit les problèmes qui se posent
aujourd'hui dans les transports en
commun il est absolument scandaleux de
faire espérer des solutions qui
n'arriveront pas mais l'accord n'est pas
définitif le débat public continue
jusqu'à la fin du mois et les travaux ne
devraient pas débuter avant 2013 alors
valérie pécresse pour l'ump estime que
finalement le tracé reprend le projet du
gouvernement à 90% ces gens pollution
qui a cédé il a bien fait pour vous moi
ce que je vois dans cet accord c'est que
les habitants de la seine-saint-denis
qu'est mon département d'élection
ben écoute et oui enfin qu'il avait été
complètement oublié par le projet de
christian blanc le grand 8 l'a enjambé
département sainte anne il allait juste
ils allaient ils commencent à s'y
intéresser à roissy qui est quand même à
l'extrémité voilà c'était un projet qui
était fait pour les hommes d'affaires
qui voulaient aller vite de la défense à
roissy mais qui en aucun cas
s'intéresser aux populations qui
habitait là nous étions une zone grise
voilà c'est résolu maintenant ça
maintenant et c'est évidemment le projet
de la région et des départements et de
tous les élus d'ailleurs de ce
département c'était de dire mais
attendez il faut aussi qu'il y ait avec
les masses financières énormes qui vont
être consacrés qui est ce projet arc
express est un projet de métro qui relie
entre elles en boucle si vous voulez
autour de paris les villes de
seine-saint-denis écoeuré l'immense
mérite en plus de désengorger le métro
parce que bon donc si vous voulez je
crois que c'est une bonne chose qui est
un accord maintenant sur la cohérence
entre les deux projets maintenant il ya
une incertitude quand même majeurs 32
milliards d'euros
il faut qu'il faut d'ailleurs jean déjà
tout de suite pour parce que vous voyez
bien en seine-saint-denis de
ces mâles donc ça marche ça m'allait
métro et le rer sont bondés
les rames tombent en panne donc il ya
des urgences est en tout cas il ya quand
même subsiste encore un point
d'interrogation sur les financements
c'est clair aller ont passé la journée
de vendredi le mariage homo toujours
interdit en france
la décision était très attendue pour le
conseil constitutionnel l'interdiction
du mariage homosexuel est bien conforme
à la constitution
les sages avaient été saisis d'une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité par un couple de
femmes pacsées qui souhaitaient une plus
grande sécurité juridique pour leurs
enfants votre réaction il va dès
le moi je respecte la décision du
conseil constitutionnel
la question ce que dit le conseil
constitutionnel c'est qu' il appartient
au législateur le cas échéant de faire
évoluer la législation c'est à dire de
changer le code civil
je crois que ce qu'il faut car ça c'est
urgent c'est réglé en effet la situation
juridique et la question de l'autorité
parentale de ses parents qui sont en
couple homosexuel et qui élèvent des
enfants et ça c'est pas possible de
rester alors vous avez plusieurs
situations vous avez des enfants que
c'est les membres de ce couple ont eu
avant d'être un couple homosexuel c'est
à dire qu'ils ont eu en étant dans un
groupe hétérosexuels les cas sont très
nombreux vous avez ensuite des enfants
qui ont pu être adoptées parce que je ne
sais pas autorisés à l'étranger besoin
donc je crois qu'il est indispensable
que les enfants et cette sécurité
juridique elle s'habillait que les
parents qui élèvent les enfants puissent
se voir reconnu dans leurs autorités par
un père selon vous ça passe par une
autorisation de mariage ou par une
amélioration du pacs je pense que je
pense que d'abord il faut améliorer la
législation existante ensuite se pose la
question les fait d'autoriser ou pas
le mariage des couples homosexuels moi
je n'y suis pas défavorable
je pense que ça pose ensuite par
ricochet une foule de questions qu'il
faut régler aussi un ace que dans la
foulée parce que j'estime que des
personnes adultes
lorsqu'elles ont la liberté enfin fait
leur liberté que de vouloir il faut que
cette liberté entre personnes adultes
soit reconnue mais dès lors que l'on
autoriserait le mariage se pose la
question de savoir si ces couples
homosexuels peuvent adopter les enfants
avoir accès à la procréation
médicalement assistée et là
les choses se compliquent un peu parce
que comment est ce qu'on écrit dans le
code civil voilà je ne dis pas que pour
l'adoption n'est pas solution là non
plus qui me paraît indispensable en tout
cas c'est que dans le code civil on
écrive bien et dans les papiers d'état
civil que un enfant est né d'un homme et
d'une femme même si un enfant a dans la
vie sociale et dans sa filiation sociale
de papa et de maman au départ il ya
forcément un homme et une femme parce
que ça c'est la loi que technicienne
mais on dise on a petit peu long
réticente est ce que oui
vous pensez que le parti socialiste doit
faire cette proposition pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2012 2 proposait donc
une loi qui autoriserait le mariage de
personnes du même sexe je pense qu'on
peut dire clairement nous avons nous
avons pris position pour la légalisation
du mariage des couples homosexuels
nous avons pris position à la faveur des
lois bioéthiques donc voilà je pense
qu'une question pour la présidentielle
est un bonne t on verra quelles sont les
priorités moi je pense je comprends que
ça intéresse beaucoup de monde mais ce
sont des actions de sociétés où vous
avez bien vu à traverser le pacs est
sensible dans l'opinion et là on vous
attend vous êtes un porte arrière je
suis pas en arrière je dis que ça pose
des questions qui sont compliqués et
qu'il faut résoudre et que je pense que
ça doit se résoudre dans la sérénité
et que ces questions elles ne doivent
pas être l'otage d'un débat politicien
voilà alors est ce que l'élection
présidentielle est le meilleur moment je
ne sais pas moi ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'on apporte des réponses sereine aux
questions que sa pose et en particulier
au regard des enfants parce que pense
que la liberté des adultes moi ça me
pose aucun problème au contraire mais
dès lors que des enfants sont en jeu là
il ya quand même certaines questions
qu'on peut pas esquiver qu'il faut
traiter sérieusement mais pour finir
cette émission juste un petit duo fillon
mélenchon côte à côte pour recevoir le
prix du trombinoscope françois fillon
couronné homme politique de l'année jean
luc mélenchon melanson révélation
politique jules et halo correct
ils sont à la politique ce que les
oscars sont au cinéma les prix du
trombinoscope la consécration pour les
meilleurs interprètes de l'année est le
meilleur premier rôle is françois fillon
triomphe du fair play de l'élégance
puisque vous avez choisi un premier
ministre qui ne présentent ni les atouts
d'un jeune premier vous l'avez même
qualifié
avait dit que ce n'était pas un enfant
de choeur ni les après d'un personnage
décoiffant voilà presque quatre ans que
j'ai l'honneur de servir mon pays à
matignon et comme à hollywood le
microcosme politique a lui aussi ses
enfants terribles catégorie meilleur
espoir à 59 ans tout de même jean-luc
mélenchon plus en forme que jamais et
mesdames et messieurs les hypermétropes
vous ne l'avez donc pas vu arriver vous
imaginez le sentiment qui mettra et par
qui révélé
par ceux là même que j'avais envoyé au
diable bref une affiche de rêve pour la
photo de famille pour les sourires en
revanche prière datant de l'année
prochaine
alors jean luc mélenchon révélation
politique mais aussi épine dans le pied
des socialistes
donc c'est un excellent orateur perçoit
pas dire le contraire
voilà
maintenant
je trouve que il a
il a des prises de positions bon il a sa
logique politique moi je crois
profondément que jean luc mélenchon veut
prendre le contrôle du parti communiste
voilà donc une logique qu'il amène
évidemment a essayé de se démarquer le
plus possible n'a pas de quoi vous
inquiété par son positionnement à gauche
peut-être plus évident que celui du
parti socialiste
non mais je crois que là la
présidentielle et législatives c'est pas
une course à qui va et ce que c'est moi
qui sinon c est ce que qui peut apporter
des vraies réponses au problème des
françaises et des français bon je pense
que les françaises et les français sont
assez mûrs assez adultes pour voir que
c'est pas dans la surenchère
politique pour pas dire plus que se
trouve la réponse à leurs problèmes il
va sur parole que nous allons nous
quitte elisabeth guigou merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous emmanuelle seigner
ressens une grande émotion que j'annonce
que nous faisions notre dernière
émission ensemble
vous allez lui quitté vous partez vers
d'autres cieux sur lci la chaîne tout
info voilà vous êtes resté but en huit
ans on y
travaille aussi pour les chaînes
parlementaires et aux non à la
république et dernière invitée pour moi
c'était les helvètes digoust
plaisir et un grand intérêt aussi merci
merci à tous de votre aussi à toute
l'équipe pour ces huit années de passion
politique partagée journaliste équipes
techniques tous ceux qui ont fait qu'on
fait ces émissions le plus la façon la
plus sérieuse et la plus conviviale à la
fois merci en tout cas d'avoir en avoir
été le témoin on vous souhaite bonne
chance à malley loup pour la suite et
puis nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine même lieu même heure au revoir